[Music]
today's question comes from mike in
pennsylvania my kid is most likely not
going to college i was always taught
that everyone goes to college how do i
help him find his path
this is a good question especially in
light of so many of the discussions
we've been having recently around
college and the pressure to go to
college and take out student loans and
the borrowed future documentary where
we're exposing this toxic culture you
know so many people have been told that
you have to go to college to be
successful and that's the only way at
all cost and that's just simply not true
college is not for everyone it's a great
thing we we love education i'm a big
believer in education but it's not for
everyone but for generations it's been
told that you have to go
so mike i do understand you know the
concern about your kid not going to
college and one of the first things i
would do is work through your own
emotions around that you know try to
think through you know why do i feel
this way what kind of fear do i have
with my kid maybe not being successful
and what are your worries and concerns
settle that in yourself and then
approach your student and your child
because the thing is is it's so easy to
kind of weave your opinion in and
kind of get aggressive and then the wall
goes up and then your kid doesn't want
to talk to you about anything they don't
want to talk about the future and that
line of communication is kind of closed
so what i do want is for you to still
have that line of communication open and
really ask your kid questions about what
do they want to do and help them explore
what that future could potentially look
like set goals you know there's a lot of
different ways to get an education it's
not just the traditional four-year
degree you know maybe they go to work
doing an apprenticeship maybe they go to
trade school maybe they get a
certificate there's a lot of different
ways to get educated to have a
successful career but you want them to
be willing to talk to you and not just
shut down because they think that you
only want one thing you know keep that
line open there's so many different
options and then also it's important to
set clear boundaries you know if your
kid is potentially lazy and is thinking
i don't want to go to college because
i'm going to sit here and you know stay
at home and kind of mooch off you for
the rest of my life like that
conversation needs to happen too you
know perhaps they do stay home for a
period as they work and kind of figure
out what's next but it's important to
kind of set that boundary of like you
know maybe if you stay here you need to
pay rent or if you stay here here are
the rules but one of the biggest things
is just keeping that line of
communication open and having those
discussions
yeah but because an eagle that doesn't
leave the nest eventually is known as a
turkey so um
you know that that needs to happen but
the other thing is this you need to
remember that
as a parent um
somewhere along the line
in our culture we have slipped a gear
and um
thought that okay once they're like 17
they're completely developed and they're
allowed to do whatever they want to do
and they're really really smart because
they're young and beautiful no they're
not
they're young and dumb
and they need a mom and they need a dad
to look at them and go that's not smart
you know you need to tell them the truth
because you've still got more influence
even than you think you do even if they
roll their eyes you've got more
influence than you think you do now
here's what would be at my house okay
100 of you
that leave this house
need to plan on a life
long
pursuit of learning
if you don't keep learning
you're dying
if the last time you read a non-fiction
book was 15 years ago you got a problem
if the last time you ever took any kind
of a class of any kind was a decade ago
you got a problem
i teach classes for a living and i take
classes
i read books like crazy that are
non-fiction and fiction
and so uh constantly have a book open
uh you know and so
i'm going to tell junior i don't know
why you're saying he's not going to
school i don't know what why why you've
come to that conclusion but
not going to a four-year school that's
fine but you're going to do something
you're going to engage in some kind of a
cert program some kind of a trade school
program uh some kind of a
uh code school whatever it is you're
gonna do you're gonna you need to do
something post high school because
you're gonna be at a
vast disadvantage your probability of
poverty goes way up unless you engage in
a lifetime of learning and it starts
with what your first post-high school
decision is
now again you won't be a diesel mechanic
i'm good with that i know diesel
mechanics making over 100k
and they love working they love working
in the grease and they love turning the
wrench and they're good at it and they
they they're you know they're engine
whisperers they can do it man i love
them and you want to do that that's cool
go do that you'll make more than
somebody that gets a sociology degree
with masters okay so have at it i'm good
with that but the uh uh the idea that
you get to do nothing post high school
that's not even on the table
and as his dad you need to influence him
starting now on that
and so okay we gonna do something bubba
what is it what is it we gonna do okay
game on all right and that's what you
need to do here and plug into that
that's gonna be a big deal
and uh and as you said college isn't for
everyone uh and you know you did post
graduate work i didn't uh i did some
postgraduate work i didn't complete a
postgraduate degree you did but um the
uh
you know the idea that somehow okay i i
i wrote an app and i made a million
dollars and i'm 19. doesn't mean you're
done bubba it means you just got started
and you got a really good start but if
you think you're going to keep doing
that over and over and over again for
the rest of your life with absolutely no
training
not happening you got lucky and fell
backward into that one and so you need
to you need to figure out a way to
replicate this and usually that involves
some form of education
now i'll hire people in the technology
field all day long who don't have a
four-year degree but have all the certs
and they've been to code school and they
can write code and they know what
they're doing most of the best ones
don't have a four-year degree in that so
we got 300 400 tech folk in the building
you know we got coders and engineers
software engineers all over the building
and hiring them every day we love them
and that four-year degree is not
necessary there but i really don't want
you doing my accounting as my cfo if you
don't have a four-year degree in that
because that's pretty basic stuff
you know and so you've got to decide
what the training is for the career
direction you want to go continuous
lifetime of learning
that you need to demand
regardless of what little child boy
wants to do here we're going we're going
to lay out some other stuff here that's
going to be the plan this is the ramsey
show